[Music]
the final speaker in today's camp
sessions and energy systems is Kampala
and he'll talk about the flow of money
thank you very much
great to be here what a wonderful
Institute the Symons program isn't okay
so I'm going to give first an overview
of electricity markets as they are you
know so and then we'll end with more of
what opportunities there might be
specific to real time decision-making
so I'll start with a history so until
around 1990 early 1990s you have the
traditional vertical integrate
vertically integrated monopolies where a
single entity owned generation
transmission distribution and retail and
the reason is because it's expensive to
build power systems and for on the
transmission so the distribution side it
doesn't make sense to have you know two
sets of independently owned wires come
into your house they're that redundancy
doesn't make sense and also people are
perceived that power quality
uninterruptible ax t in power was so
important I mean we could not sort of
let it be left to the whimsy of markets
so but these monopolies were Geographic
you know sir-sir regional and a single
entity as I said owned all these four
functions and even if you have
monopolies they have to be regulated
because you know we know that monopolies
will extract however much profit they
possibly can private monopolies would
abuse their power so so what we do is we
regulate or what we did was we regulated
them in the sense that they receive
these monopoly rights in exchange for
controls on the retail tariffs they they
impose on their customers and the public
utility commission or
some governing body sets these tariffs
so that the utility recovers its
operational cost its capital cost and
the utility can pay its investors a fair
return on their rate of return so that's
the way it was and the problem is
monopolies are inefficient so utilities
can actually earn more if they invest
more if they make mistakes these
mistakes are simply passed on to the
rate payer there's no competition and
that's that's a little bit of a problem
there's as I said there's no penalty for
poor investment choices the public picks
up all the costs for mistakes and so and
then what about this this business of
regulating monopolies well these are you
know three to five public officials and
elected officials and you know they may
not know a thing about electricity
markets there so there's the ignorance
problem
pravin is shaking its head I shouldn't
be actually giving this talk everything
I know is a strict and small subset or
what Praveen has taught me so just as
you all know that and the other problem
with elected officials is they want to
get reelected you know so that's that's
a problem you know should also get rid
of tenure
so the consequences in this
vertically-integrated regulated local
monopoly model is that the retail rights
the retail electricity tariffs are
higher than they should be it's very
it's very not very transparent you just
get a bill and you pay it because it's
small anyway relatively there's systemic
waste a lot of problems with this
so 1990s people said let's introduce
competition that's deregulate the
electricity markets let's do this by
unwell in some in some jurisdictions
some countries they did they did this by
selling you know publicly owned
utilities you know privatizing them but
in the u.s. they decide to unbundle the
functions of the utility treat
electricity is a commodity much to
Shawn's chagrin and to create markets to
trade this commodity I agree with Shawn
I'll come back to to that point that you
know it is not really a commodity for
very good reasons the trends the
transmission and generate and
distribution remain natural local
monopolies because you don't want two
sets of wires generators compete against
each other and hopefully this will this
competition will induce wisdom in
investment choices will reduce tariffs
you know all these wonderful things and
we'll also have retail choice we don't
have it everywhere we have it in the
Texas jurisdiction and a few other
places you know retail choice isn't
quite here the picture you see the green
states that have largely adopted this
deregulated model the white states are
the ones in there are not green are the
ones that have not have stayed with the
traditional model you can also overlay
this with an electoral map and see you
know how it correlates okay
so the expected benefits and problems
with this deregulated model well the
benefits are that the consumers will pay
fairly for it they receive and not for
mistakes that utilities have made
there's transparency you know what
you're paying for maybe you get a
separate line item for this
in charge for energy charge for taxes
for you know things like that and in the
long term there is the hope that this is
a greater efficiency there are problems
you know with this deregulated model one
is much greater price volatility in the
wholesale market so this is a picture
you know in California I guess I can see
the numbers thousand Texas Shawn put up
summers 3000 and there's an example from
one of Shawn's talks where in February
2001 the wholesale price intercut spiked
to 3000 dollars for three hours and
generators made a profit of half a
billion dollars that does count towards
GDP I believe you know but I don't know
how they do that accounting so you know
it's not an altogether bad thing for
companies to make profits I guess
possibly lower reliability you know when
when things are centrally we have a
integrated monopoly you can point a
finger at somebody you know and so oh
the transmission broke or the generation
broke you know there's a reliability
sort of can be a little bit of an issue
has the experiment of whatever 20 years
or so worked you know opinions are
divided it's kind of complicated
prices are slightly lower in the
deregulated states but but unbundling
that lower price is a little difficult
because in California we tax the hell
out of everything you know and I I
support taxes
okay I am my politics are left but they
are well right of provin Mariah okay
is this reduction in price - again if
done but visit because you know fuel
prices have gone down and wind is still
cheap you know some people have worked
hard to justify it and there are lots of
papers and you know of course you know
in this era of alternate facts you can
be the same thing and come to two
different conclusions so I'm going to
give you a brief overview of power
system operations as they stand today
again a very high-level view many of the
elements here have been talked in more
detail
you know by Stephen lo by Sean so I just
just give you the core problem is
balancing supply and demand that's the
problem but you have to do it
economically through markets you want to
do it with transmission constraints and
lines can only carry so much power there
are thermal limits things like that you
want to maintain power quality voltage
frequency you want to assure reliability
against failures of lines of generations
you know so you want to have that
reliability and this thing is this
balancing of supply and demand isn't
managed by System Operator or a
transmission whatever it's go to here so
and so that's the core problem and today
I'm going to talk about load and I'm
going to talk about the problem today
today renewables are modest there aren't
we aren't at 50% renewables or something
like that so we talk about net load net
load is the actual load minus the
renewable so it's really the Lord left
over that has to be serviced by
conventional generation and today what
we do is we adjust the supply to meet
the random demand
okay that's what we do we have
controllable supply to meet random the
man and tomorrow when you have much more
renewables and when you have maybe loads
that are adjustable like like the water
heaters that Shauna needed to like pool
pumps that he works on buildings then
tomorrow
the approach and there's a fair
consensus on this so tomorrow the
approaches to tailor the demand to
follow the random supply we'll come back
to that
for now I'll talk about what goes on now
so again see this is a sort of a
stylized model you know the actual
system operations are complex they vary
tremendously across jurisdictions as Joe
is saying you know in England they have
a capacity market I think and then in
Florida they don't have in Singapore
they they don't have a day ahead might
have a single a real time market so it's
a very solid place what I'm giving you a
roughly a common framework
the idea is you construct the supply to
meet the random demand and use both
feedback and feed for Sophie forward
means you use forecasts of the net load
and you construct supply from various
sources to meet this forecasted demand
time goes by you get a better forecast
and you fine-tune the collection of
generation assets you have assembled to
meet the the net load feedback is used
sort of in real time or slightly after
the fact when you measure something and
make a correction you measure the
frequency a frequency deviation from
system frequency of 60 Hertz is an
indicator of an imbalance between power
in between supply and demand and you
make these Corrections very quickly
using AGC and things like that so these
two mechanisms I'm going to largely talk
about feed-forward the market mechanism
for doing this so roughly there are two
kinds of markets there's their head and
there's real time they had you buy power
in one-hour blocks to meet a forecast of
the net load again that's load minus
renewables in real time you buy power in
five minute blocks to sort of two using
a better forecast so you sort of trim
your positions that you made a day ahead
and then
you do that in the real-time market it's
under it's in quotes because in
California for example the real-time
market closes 37 and a half minutes
before delivery it's not real time as we
understand and then after the fact using
feedback you have regulation for very
fine imbalances based on measurement of
frequency and things like that movies it
you might have to pay for capacity for
regulation services in addition to
energy and this balancing is done in
various time scale some assets can do
balancing for maybe five minutes and
they have to hand it off to other assets
in case there's a serious dip in
frequency and so on yes yes you do yeah
you can take positive and negative
positions yes are these are these
lengths of time associated with the
physical systems or are these
conveniences for traders the physical
system hasn't really kicked in until
times zero we're talking about one day
in advance and 37 minutes in advance and
so this is just either the way it's
evolved there's nothing seasonal no no
okay
so I have some nice picture it took me
forever to put together and lay tack so
here we go
the black curve is the day ahead
forecast and in one hour blocks you know
because of my limitation I stopped in a
four hour day you buy one hour blocks in
the day ahead market and then you get a
better forecast so you know the black
line before became a more nuanced black
line better forecast one hour in advance
let's say and now you fill these you
know so the then you have a different
imbalance that's you know you've already
taken a position what's left over is the
red curve and you buy these five minute
blocks in the real-time market the the
day ahead market also called the
wholesaler above power market really
carries 90% of the volume or more and
the real time
also called the balancing market is much
less okay and then even after that
you're done you're done with the market
story they still find bile imbalances of
supply and demand and then this is done
using freak regulation and you buy like
a capacity for example for regulation
services to do with that thing and it's
done in various time scales sub for
second it's done completely
automatically and the generators have
something called governor control which
is disappearing because governors aren't
being compensated for that so that's
going out the picture and now this AGC
thing for seconds as Sean was talking
about so that's what goes on and that
centralized governor that generation
responds to system operator commands s
so Center for System Operator the person
who is charged with balancing supply and
demand so that's my sort of summary now
let's talk about the markets behind day
ahead and real time here so first I want
to talk to you about pools and bilateral
trading so the seller is I'm going to
talk about are generating companies
people who own coal plants nuclear
plants combined cycle gas turbines
whatever and the buyers are utility
companies are also called load serving
entities they buy energy or power in the
wholesale market and resell it to
residential customers small industrial
consumers commercial and then the big
guys like Google can participate
directly in the wholesale market by
passing the load serving it so many
jurisdictions use use long term
bilateral contracts and so these are
decentralized so there's no these are
private arrangements between two parties
a buyer and a seller and the price and
for the price and the price information
is private they could also be short-term
in an OTC or over-the-counter market
what that simply means is you see these
long term bilateral contracts take a
long time to negotiate
you know you you know they just take a
while till you have to worry about all
the terms what if they miss a target and
so on whereas in the OTC market they
standardized the product making it much
easier to to trade in a standardized
product and then even below that their
electronic exchanges to sort of make
this even simpler so the system operator
doesn't know anything about the prices
all they have to be told about is the
volume of the power exchange between who
where are they so that you know they can
assure system reliability worried about
transmission constraints and so on so
these bilateral contracts are unsuitable
for this real-time market because you
can't leave this fine but the balance
the eventual balance of supply and
demand up to the whimsy of the market
though this is changing with electronic
trading and so on
so the real-time market is typically not
a bilateral arrangement between buyers
and sellers renewables today most of
them are simply traded in long term
bilateral contracts or what about power
purchase agreements and the purchase
price is a good indicator of the net of
the actual cost of renewals if people
are willing to pay that that's sort of
the cost of renewables now our focus is
on these things called pool markets
which is very different than a bilateral
transaction of the contract between say
pravin and myself here it's centralized
these are decentralized here generators
submit bids a price and quantity I will
I'm willing to sell you this much at
this price the system operate and and
they forgot to tell you the load serving
entities or utilities might submit
demand bids I think they're not
convinced but anyway so that is we're
willing to buy this much at this price
but demand is largely inelastic
okay so let's even take that off the
table let's just generator submit price
and quantity bids the system operator
determines the dispatch this means which
generators will generate electricity
how much
[Music]
that's what the system operator does in
an organized bull market the system
operator also determines the prices it's
the market maker it clears the market
and sometimes you have a mix of
bilateral and pool markets you know
that's fine you can put those in there
too and you're basically the the
bilateral people participate and accept
these prices but then they hedge against
them using other things like prices by
contracts for differences and so on but
you can mix the two okay well let's keep
it clean bilateral okay so how our pool
markets cleared by the system operator
let's assume for now there are no
transmission constraints no losses so
just like you know perfect electricity
grid you have all these generating
companies and then you have inelastic
load so which generations do you pick
well the generators submit the supply
offers price and quality constraints
your minimum generation maximum
generation maybe even duration I must
run for five hours things like that and
the load serving entities that also
submits a demand bid based on forecast
it's inelastic so let's say it's just a
quantity okay this system operat
constructs what's called a merit order
stacks which should organize these
generators from cheapest to most
expensive looks at the demand draws a
line and says off that's the price okay
I'll show you a picture next time so
they in the next slide so the generators
will receive this clearing the price
uniform clearing price all generators
receive that same price it's not pay as
bid so if a you know a nuclear plant bid
say $2 a mega mega watt of a megawatt
hour with the clearing price is 20 they
receive 20 okay not pay is bid why do we
don't do pay as bid and we just give a
uniform clearing a uniform price to all
the participants because the sense of
right investment signal an efficient
generator will make a larger profit and
so we're we're rewarding efficiency
we're making that
a good thing to have and so people will
try to become more efficient in the long
term that's the motivation for pay as
bid okay the result is efficient and
yeah from just elementary theory of the
firm it maximizes social welfare under
truthful bidding by the way these bids
can be strategic you don't have to
actually bid the generators don't have
to bid they're true costs they just
submit bids nobody's a checking well is
that really how much it costs for you to
make electricity you know so that's a
strategic bit okay so here's the merit
ordering you have all these generators
and then you you would stack them up
from the least expensive to the most
expensive and here I had like loads
bidding different amounts but really the
load is just a vertical line you
intersect you get the price and then
those generators below the price that's
called the marginal price or whatever
the ones below are in front those are
the ones that are that are called on to
produce electricity and the ones above
you know tough luck okay so that's how
it goes the network case is much more
interesting so again we have load L and
Generation G and you know we model say
the generation costs may be submitted to
the system operator again they can be
strategic they can be linear or in there
they are linear piecewise linear I think
California allowed to submit nine points
okay so let's assume they're convex fuel
costs a minimum and a maximum so you
have this set of inequality constraints
the load is given it's an elastic that's
given we have the DC power flow model
that that just even talked about and
what it says is there are these bus
angles times a matrix admittance matrix
is the net injection G minus L at each
bus okay then you have line capacity
constraints some matrix times theta less
than or equal to some given set of
vectors the social cost is the sum of
the costs of all the generators so the
problem data a bunch of matrices and
vectors and cost function
these can be usually piecewise-linear
and the decision variables are G and
theta okay so there are two problems one
is called economic dispatch I'm given a
set of generators I will use a set of
committed generators what is our the
generator generation levels to meet a
given load at minimum cost that's the
problem
economic dispatch and it's a linear or
convex program it can be included to
sort of full nonlinear power flow models
that Steven alluded to but then the
problem is not a linear program or a
convex program and the output of this
economic dispatch is to tell me which
gen to tell me the generator levels how
much each committed generator should
produce and what the system clearing
price is I said prices because in the
trend in the network case the prices are
different at different locations
okay unit commitment is a problem that
sits above the economic dispatch and it
asks to know which generators should I
use okay so in this case you add these
binary decision variables alpha now 0 or
1 which generators use you run economic
dispatcher solve the problem find the
cost go back so really what you have is
a is a mixed integer program much harder
ok so these are the problems that that
people study and I'll focus on economic
dispatch because it's a nice clean
problem so the simplified timeline again
is that the generators submit bid curse
load submit demand forecasts and
one-hour blocks if I'm talking about the
day ahead mark it's very similar for the
real-time the system operator determines
the economic dispatch how much general
each generation produce and the clearing
price at each bus called the locational
marginal price and the loads are
obligated to purchase power at that
price and the generators are obligated
to supply this generation that is
specified by the system operator and
receive the the locational marginal
price the price at which at the node at
which they are injecting
then you proceed to the real-time market
there are lots of important details have
omitted you know no child can maybe come
back to later all participants at bus I
face a price lambda I regardless of
their bids okay okay so the economic
dispatch problem is minimize system cost
subject to the Kirchhoff's voltage law
and Kirchhoff's current law this is the
DC power flow model transmission line
constraints on the capacity minimum
maximum generation maximum generation
now if this the generation costs are
piecewise linear you can see we have a
linear probe a dual variable for this
constraint the power flow constraint is
called the locational marginal price
there's one per bus the dual variables
for the transmission constraints are
called the congestion prices I won't
talk much about that so these locational
marginal price prices the interpretation
of the dual variable is the price of
delivering one extra unit of energy at
that bus if there's no congestion then
all the prices at all the locational
marginal prices are the same everywhere
yeah if even one line is congested say
the line over there between nodes 1 & 4
is congested then the prices at all the
other nodes not even connected directly
to that bus change okay so after the
what is the payment made to the
generators it's the prices the vector of
prices dot you know transpose times the
generation quantity that the system
operator comes up with the dispatch the
total payment from the loads is this
fortunately the system operator who
makes the market never loses money okay
the payments received from the loads is
always bigger than the payments shelled
out to the generators and that
difference is called a merchandising
surplus in part it is used to support
what I call financial transmission
rights but you know they'll actually
make even more money most a lot of the
time because it's in an auction but in
the long run merchandising surplus is
used to support other things that the
utility that the system wants new light
transmission expansion okay this is a
very simple example I have two
generators a cheap and expensive one
there's no load over here there's a load
over here of five units and there's a
transmission line with capacity ten I
would use the cheap generator and it
goes five units of power go from here
the cheap generator along the line to
the load uncongested the marginal price
of supplying one more unit of energy
here is pipeline because I can still use
the cheap generate suppose the line is
congested the load is demanding fifteen
units of power you can only get ten from
this cheap generator so you have to buy
five from this expensive generator the
locational marginal price is now by 2 so
this Lord Peis by two for all of its 15
units ok ok
these MPs are counter intuitive counter
turbine flows and in in prices
electricity is not like wheat or roses
we would not ship roses from San
Francisco to Anchorage they're grown
here I think ok and it would cost more
sorry we would not ship we've not
Shepard you got ok
so electricity cannot be stored I mean
it can be stored in batteries but not in
large quantities at reasonable cost okay
so these LMP so you so these lmps could
be firstly they can be negative as Sean
showed in his thing they can exceed the
marginal cost of any one generator even
the most expensive yeah they can be all
over the map and then there's the
braised paradox which is if you think
you know what I'm going to invest in a
transmission line make it high
capacity that should relieve congestion
and reduce costs
not necessarily okay yes if you make the
cost if you make if you ultimately if
you make that transmission all
transmission lines infinitely big
you know then yes but you know a small
amount of strengthening mods it is can
increase prices okay that's called the
brace balance one more thing here this
expensive generator has I'm jet lag
market power over this slowly okay
because it sets the marginal price for
this guy it can say you know what when
it bends it can say oh no it's $200
sorry you're out of luck in which case
this poor lord over here has to pay $200
there's market power that generators can
exert overloads this example is too
simple in a big Network case a generator
in location at Bus a can exert market
power to on loads that are remote and
some other buses not not connected with
it with a direct link you know maybe
even though all the the the line is
emanating from this bus from this
generator are not congested can still
exert market power at remote buses so
market power is a very interesting topic
and then the last thing I want to tell
you about is band-aids and what's going
on today electricity markets are balcan
eyes okay there in practice so there are
many extra mid-market payments you know
we have to worry about startup costs and
shutdown costs about no load costs what
if this generator was not scheduled it's
still burning fuel you saw a bunch of
make-whole payments okay it's a little
murky sometimes how that's done so the
minute you have you know side payments
it's called like extra market it's not
being done in some transparent way
there's subsidies preferential
treatments we're now about to see a huge
preferential treatment for the coal for
coal-fired plants I think the production
credits in all sorts of things
their attempts to retain very important
participants to assure to show some
liquidity there all these things that
balcony is the market and these things
increase in efficiencies because we're
now stepping away from you know a clean
competitive marketplace but the economic
or orthodoxy an i Jewish Borenstein were
here you know he he says you know spark
markets real-time pricing is the only
thing you need you know I disagree with
him maybe a little more modestly than
other folks one argument that people say
are real time pricing consumers you know
you don't want to pay you deal with all
this volatility you know but I'm sure
there'll be other company will be
insurance companies that come and take
away the volatility risk at a price
that's fine but the real-time pricing
our objection doesn't come from from
that a spam the volatility aspect but
more from that there are different
commodities and we'll talk about that in
a second okay retail tariffs that's in
the end the smaller consumers what did
they pay that's what a tariff is and as
I said the larger participants
participate directly in the wholesale
market and the smaller ones have to buy
from the utility it's reselling and
there generally is retail tires have
been generally fixed they're set they
don't you know there isn't like you wake
up in the morning guess how much a
kilowatt hour of electricity costs it's
pretty much set and I said as I said the
economic orthodoxy is real-time pricing
that's where people want to get towards
and people are sort of creeping towards
that right now you have volumetric or
tiered pricing so for the first 20 units
of electricity you pay this much for the
next 20 units you pay a higher rate and
so on and so forth just sort of
discourage you from consuming from
wasting electricity you have time-of-use
pricing which is like during during
times when electricity is scarce and
expensive the price is more okay again
trying to approximate real-time price in
California this is already here time
is available its opt-in but you know in
a year or two it's going to be opt-out
so the default will be time of use price
and then industrial consumers pay I
don't know anything residential
consumers are faced with critical peak
pricing but that's in addition to your
payment for energy they calculate your
monthly peak and you pay you pay for the
peak so they want to try and make your
your usage not peaky but as flat as
possible for industrial consumers the
the peak price the critical peak price
can be comparable to the energy price
paid on a monthly basis so much for oh
there are other markets that I won't
talk to you about markets for inertia
capacity transmission expansion
transmission rights virtual goods I want
to talk to about all of these because I
kind of want to focus on real time
decision-making which is the apparent
theme of our
okay that's my sort of status quo
summary I have till five o'clock right
yeah okay okay so things fall apart so
utilities have had a you know this is
long ago you know so now things have
gotten better utilities are in trouble
you know that European utilities have
lost a lot of money if the problem is
more serious in Europe than it is in the
United States because we print money
that's no problem and it's partly
because and I'll tell you why it's
because the embrace of renewal okay
Germany has you know has embarked on a
really profound and applauded about
experiment to bring in so much
renewables so much and they're rewarding
the people who do this pig farmers in
Munich are stopping producing pigs and
it's more lucrative for them to to sell
energy
okay the price of sausage is apparently
skyrocketed okay solar prices are
falling modulo of the recent import
tariffs that Trump is announced you know
there are lots of troubling facts I
won't read through them but utilities
are convinced that their business model
is under threat and they're losing okay
and it's because of renewables okay
and so why is this crisis driven by
renewable so this is the situation now
you have the load in black and then you
have this something called base load so
that's like a nuclear plant or a big
coal plant this must run okay
and so it so they just pay bid zero so
they're gonna run because it's too
expensive for them to turn on and off
their their generation and then what's
left over is the market like like this
day ahead market wholesale market I
alluded to and then you know there's
volatility even in a single day of the
you know of the load or even in a single
hour and you have reserves so there's a
little bit of reserves you need
different kind of generation in a
fast-acting generation a gas fire plant
typically for so that's the picture
today now you throw in renewables which
they cycle let's see they're solar so up
and down up and down I see a lot of
renewables there also must run because
they're marginal cost is zero so you
take them okay and when you do that the
base load again is free to I mean must
run its here the market drops to 25
percent 25 so the you know so this is
where the utilities are right now
they're bidding into the day head market
with their with their with their plants
and it that's why they're losing money
you know this is an exaggerated cartoon
but you know that's why they're losing
money also notice that these fast-acting
plants you need a lot more of the
reserves because the renewables are up
and down and moreover you only need them
for like half the time or one third of
the time so the capacity factor is small
so I I do agree that these fast-acting
gas fire turbines that provide reserves
in an era of lots of renewables they
worry about not being compensated
because yes there's a lot of them but
they only run one third of the time
okay so who would I invest it I need
some guarantee of rate of return so
perhaps a capacity market for reserves
is the right thing I don't know okay so
it's all this renewables and variability
and as I said you know there are other
problems like wind ramps and things like
that and more need for more regulation
and various of various kinds the people
say that you will need three times more
reserves and all sorts of things like
that
the bottom line is where people are now
saying look let's try to tailor demand
to meet random supply as opposed to
tailor supply to meet random demand so
different a paradigm shift so addressing
this crisis there are all sorts of new
business models that utilities are
exploring you know whether it's leasing
your rooftop putting their own renu but
you're basically getting into their new
rules themselves you know owning that
production so they're not completely
displaced from the market segment and
offering information services you know
knowing you know just metering knowing
your customer all sorts of things like
that they're trying to reduce
operational expenses again using
information technology and so on okay
let me leave it at that so finally a
critique of the legacy markets that I
described the day I had you know the
pooled or bilateral the to settlement
market is it you know they were designed
for slow-acting conventional generation
they were designed in the era of
coal-fired plants of nuclear plans
perhaps that's why day ahead that's
where that came from one day I need to
generate all that steams gonna take me a
while and that's where that came from
they need lead time and also why
one-hour well these big things these big
generation they can't change on a dime
okay so that's where these things came
also the flow of information is just
top-down it's just you know the
except in the last bit to measure
frequency and make a trim it's all the
same
the new opportunities new problems so a
lot more renewables some parts of load
like water heaters pool pumps are
controllable there is demand response
there are new sensing assets micro PM
use there's all sorts of their smart
meters everywhere there's their new
power electronics devices that can do
miraculous things or which I know very
little so there's so there's a lot of
activity in this and all of these things
suggest maybe we need new market ideas
that's what I'll talk about 9 possible
new market things but not all of these
have come to to pass but I'm gonna put
them out there and these are ones the
ones I chose are because they're
connected to real-time decision-making
most by by by and large so let's start
with renewables you all know that
renewables are intermittent and random
and uncontrollable I just want to put up
the plot of solar power
one day in Arizona at 10 second sampling
one month in the Nordic grid and one
hour sampling the spectral nature of
this randomness is really quite
different ok so you might for example
have a small amount of storage to smooth
out passing clouds and things like that
you don't need much okay but it must be
relatively fast acting so you could do
stuff like that and here in the Nordic
grid there is beard of one week where
the wind simply blows a 20% of nameplate
of the grid so then you have to really
find other assets okay so the spectral
nature of renewables is not monolithic
it varies by source by asset by jus by
by where it is okay and yet some amount
of Geographic aggregation you know will
relieve you of this is a very very very
minute but you know if it's blowing it's
windy here
and all the wind firms are on the coast
was windy up and down the coast so
there's some degree you can like
completely count on it being washed up
our renewables sold today you can when
uva's can't participate in day ahead
markets why because you have to commit
to one hour blocks day ahead your day
had forecast hours for renewables are
25% maybe renewables are not firm not
flat firm means constant in one-hour
blocks there's no renewable source with
that sort of profile you could
participate in the real time market
because you know 30 minutes ahead you
have a 3 or 2 percent forecast there and
the technique is just the very simple of
this one what's it called the previous
one the forecasting method for
renewables is to use the previous value
persistence thank you you know it's and
it's certainly you can make it if it's
not firm on 5 minute blocks you can use
a modest amount of storage to make it
firm on 5 minute blocks the volume on on
the on in the spot and the real time
market is very small so if you imagine
are gonna have 30 40 percent of my my
total energy being provided by
renewables and that doesn't quite work
ok so the wind today is mostly sold and
even transmission scale solar is sold
through bilateral contracts or Power
Purchase Agreements as I said earlier
small residential PV is sold through net
metering net metering is a program where
the you the meter runs backward in your
home you have solar you make more than
you're using your meter runs backward
okay
it's a perverse sort of program it's
like you know you have a garden at homes
and you're selling carrots and you're
there's carrots you have too many
carrots because your daughter doesn't
like carrots so you go down to Safeway
and say oh how much are you selling
carrots for okay it's a dollar twenty a
pound here all these carrots and Safeway
is obligated to buy these carrots
doesn't make sense okay
utilities hate it Safeway hates this
program so it's under severe threat
Arizona Hawaii you know so that's going
to put a big clamp on residential solar
PV in this okay what about the future
how can we sell random renewables well
you could bundle storage bundle with
storage so you have storage to make the
renewables firm okay that's a real-time
decision making problem you know so how
many when do I charge the storage when
do I discharge storage you could
aggregate with other renewable sources
or shearing okay and practice works on
stuff like that to take into account to
aggregate to take into helps to
statistical diversity where do you put
the storage when you set how you send
the command should a forecast the
renewables there's a control and a
decision making problem if you wish to
firm renewables so they can participate
in the day ahead wholesale okay next and
another thing one could do is completely
rethink the product let's not think of
energy as some you know undifferentiated
nectar see some undifferentiated thing
but a differentiated commodity so for
example there's a really interesting
lovely paper by tannin varietal you
differentiate electricity based on
reliability so for example you know I'll
sell you you know 10 kilowatt hours of
electricity with probably 0.99 you pay a
lot I'll sell you 10 kilowatts of
electricity same commodity but with
probably 0.5 you may or may not get it
and you should pay less okay that's an
interesting product it's clearly it's
not the same product that you know
you're setting unreliable and reliable
so one can explore how one prices our
product how one constructs supply to
meet demand
and you know and you know you may say
well how do you audit such a product you
know suppose you bought unreliable
electricity we're supposed to get with
chance point nine five yeah yeah how do
you know that you're not being screwed
right this is a question we should all
ask ourselves every day since
in November of last year okay well you
can do long-term auditing and count on
you know fundamental theorems in in
probability to say that in the law of
large numbers I should get okay another
differentiated product is deadlines
differentiated where you know you can
think you can say there are two kinds of
gasoline that's what I mean by product
differentiation okay unleaded super
unleaded so in deadline differentiate it
with Stephen lo le on guitar you know
you you you will receive a product of so
many hours of kilowatt hours electricity
but for the next hour for the next one
thirty two hours three hours and if you
want that firm power for longer and
longer you know maybe you have to you
know what I'm gonna get this wrong the
price should be higher oh I see that's
another way okay is that what they meant
by this Stephen that's okay thank thank
you Joe by the way you know I'm you know
there there are a lot of people here who
know way more than I do
okay let me point out some of them
Stephen low Sean main Pratyush Joe
Warrington Praveen Mariah okay so if you
have questions you know please you know
talk to
duration differentiated contracts so
here's a random power supply let's sell
slices of power what do you notice about
this slice it's on sometimes off
sometimes on sometimes off set
okay so that's another product
differentiation rethinking the product
the problem with this sort of thing is
consumers have to plan their consumption
okay well are you going to tell me when
I'm gonna get the thing how much in
advance you know things like that so let
me show you a little picture which will
connect us to real time decision making
suppose the time is slotted and I could
only draw four time slots in my in my
thing okay
instead 24 one-hour slots and they're a
bunch of customers and different
customers demand different unit amounts
of energy but they're indifferent to
which blocks they receive that energy
for example this customer one wants one
unit of energy for one hour you could
give it to him here or here or here or
here this other customer wants two units
of energy so there's the two you could
supply it here or maybe those two or any
two of the four whereas this fourth cost
this fifth customer needs four units of
energy in four times thoughts so really
they're not offering you any flexibility
you simply have to provide energy in
every one of those times another example
of product differentiation but now you
have a lot of questions if the supply is
known when is it adequate to service
this given collection of consumers if
it's adequate what is the allocation if
it's not you may need to purchase extra
power what is minimum purchase what is
the policy what is the purchase policy
if the random supply is revealed in run
time so lots of research problems in
controls in real-time decision-making
and policies and how do you present
combined with economics okay so how do
you price how do you price
these differentiated products quantity
and H hours delivered for H hours of the
24 so these are interesting questions
risk limiting dispatch so this is
concerned with you know right now I
talked about a day ahead market and real
time which is really 30 minutes in
advance you know your Renewable forecast
they had a 30 percent 25 percent
uncertainty whereas you know 30 minutes
before you pretty much know how windy it
is so this to settlement they had real
time market structure is a legacy of
nuclear and coal fire plants it's not
favorable to wind and solar so perhaps
we should construct a series of
intermediate markets to make digesting
of renewables because of the uncertainty
in renewables more favorable okay so now
you have a random load that you wish to
meet this is copied from PowerPoint that
should be L okay and that's what you
know so and then again like in the day
head you buy a big block in a one-hour
block next market you buy a 30-minute
block a 10-minute block a five-minute
block so you construct your supply to
meet this random demand in a series of
markets but the twist is you have
information about your demand this is
the little delivery time you know this
far away I have you know much more
uncertainty in my knowledge of the net
load and as I progress I have more and
more information and I'm it can make
better and better decisions but the key
thing is the key thing is you make these
future decisions aware that you will
have a recourse opportunity okay it
isn't that you're simply optimizing your
purchase in this market at this time
it's optimizing this given that you will
have these future opportunities and that
you will have statistically this much
better forecast information
so it's a complicated problem this is
called risk limiting dispatch you can
read more about it in this excellent
paper and you can see it's real-time
decision-making so I saw this slide in
their paper this is a decision decision
decision decision so this is the perfect
and real time real time so this is a
perfect picture to put up without
getting into the details of except to
say that it is a threshold policy okay
electricity storage it's very expensive
$300 per kilowatt hour for a lithium I'm
les it's 270 something it's falling fast
it's more surrounded by the fancy that
Tesla batteries 400 or so it's a
game-changer of the transmission skill
if you can do a lot of storage there but
you know before you even get there there
are many distribution side applications
like arbitrage against time-of-use
pricing you're me if I have high and low
prices I charge the battery when it's
you know and so on a voltage support
trading between peer firms that's work
by delete calathea
here so let's just look at one example
the industrial firm it faces what are
called critical peak prices wellmaybe
faces real time prices critical peak is
you pay for a monthly peak so how do you
use your storage to flatten that monthly
peak when you don't even see it coming
okay so it's a stochastic control
problem and decision problem the
decisions are went to charge went to
discharge stream okay there's
uncertainty in price uncertainty loads
so it's a very interesting problem maybe
the problem may be that policies are
very complicated and you're a
manufacturer of this integrated storage
for companies you want a simple policy
okay because we're done working when we
call to fix it right
so are there simple suboptimal policies
that get you 90% of the way there there
are a lot of interesting problems on
Canada where your transmission scale
storage okay now I'm talk about big
storage I'm hoping that the price drops
to say a hundred and fifty hundred
twenty-five dollars per mega per
kilowatt hour of storage
so there's this mandate in California
for 1.3 gigawatts and as Sean said
that's a unit of power not energy and so
what they're really talking about here
is R and paying and other things for the
doctor they're not talking about what
I'm going to tell you about so the idea
for selling trans transmission scale
storage and this is something that you
know Hameed reserves over there as
looking at is to essentially follow this
day ahead wholesale they had economic
dispatch sort of formulation and there
you are doing selling energy in one-hour
blocks so here's the difference
utilities this is the game plan
utilities install some amount of storage
at their various buses but they don't
know when to charge and discharge that
storage because they don't know you know
surely to arbitrage they don't know what
the L MPs are going to look like they
can calculate these LM peas because that
requires private information but the
bids made by other generation companies
may be about the transmission line
congestion and the loads and they don't
have that
so rather than guess and try to do
arbitrage and charge and discharge your
storage to make money why didn't you
just throw up your hands and tell the
system operator how much storage you
have submit your demand bid now that
demand bid is also plus minus the
storage amount right so the system
operator knows that that's your nominal
but they can move suppose there are two
time periods and you have say 10 units
of storage you can shift your demand
tenure demand from one time period to
the other so the system operator knows
that and the sister operative conducts
multi period economic dispatch and
dispatches optimally not just the
generation units but your storage so you
throw up your hands and say listen I
can't do this arbitrage myself I don't
have access to a lot of private
information let the system operator
decide for me when I should charge and
discharge my store
one can show that the system of the
collection of utilities or storage
owners which might be third parties will
benefit but an individual storage of
owner at a single bus may not okay even
though they've put up their storage for
use by everybody else they may not
benefit their locational marginal prices
go up you know despite their having that
storage so then one has to rethink maybe
that we after the fact exchanges of
money to make to incentivize people to
yield their storage and you know so the
the business model for making whole
private ownership of storage is an open
one which I mean we'll be looking at the
system does benefit I think you can ask
so it's still a convex optimization
problem because the storage the
existence of storage of various buses
simply adds a convex constraint to the
economic dispatch
demand response so Sean was talking he's
not a lot excellent work on the what
hall some figure out the name of the
hall over the fans and pro beer and so
what are flexible loads electric
vehicles
you know I'm indifferent to when I when
you recharge my electric vehicle as long
as you deliver it when I need it
okay when I need it what you don't know
when I need I don't know what I need so
that's a little bit of an issue there
okay 7:00 a.m. because it's unlikely any
of us wake up before then except HVAC
systems have a thermal dead bag we want
70 degrees + - I don't know what we
can't really feel - I don't know one
degree and you can use his flexibility
monetize it in many different ways you
can view it as an up and down generation
resource FERC order something seven five
five elevates demand response to
generator status generators objected
went to litigation went to the Supreme
Court finally was approved soon evening
and then so yes now you can you know of
course how could be reversed who knows
a simple use of demand response to speak
shaving you know at these times when
electricity is scarce and expensive you
can use you can control people pay them
threaten them to reduce their demands
okay and these big prices of electricity
can be very very hot and some I think
Texas has a maximum of nine thousand
okay I think in Australia they didn't
have a peak they don't have a Mac of CAP
someplace they don't used to then this
frequency regulation which is not what
Shawn was doing there other there's so
many uses of demand response i lump it
all in one thing it can be event-driven
it can be continuously providing some
service like a backup that's what
contingency reserves are and they're two
architectures there's direct load
control where you know you just cede
control of your appliance or your
factory within certain limits your for
example industrial air conditioner just
say listen you guys run it except here's
my temperature constraint direct notice
okay that's used for example in
refrigeration warehouses direct load
control okay
in direct load control is where these
devices are controlled through prize-pot
proxies you nudge people to say not use
an appliance or to use an appliance by
by change by modulating the price of
electricity
but let's start with how do you model
demand response modeling an individual
household you know my consumption of
electricity and my flexible dishwasher
is hopeless okay but in an aggregate
there will be some predictability which
you need if you're going to offer this
in a market if you're going to offer
this demand response as a generator in
some markets providing some answering
service maybe a capacity market or in a
real time market providing you know
balancing you need some predictability
and it's hopeless to do it for one
electric vehicle when you have arrival
rates and departure rates and states of
charge that are unknown yes you can say
they're poised on and move on from there
but you know I'm not having met pause on
I don't know I'm skeptical but one can
model things conservatively so you take
all this flexibility and say I'm gonna
assure that it's at least like a battery
I'm going to leave something on the
table so the degree of flexibility which
is really a set of acceptable power
profiles for this collection of
appliances all in aggregate by a
community of individuals that collection
of admissible power profiles contains
the power profiles that our battery can
give you a battery with capacity C and
maximum charge and discharge rate an and
one can do this yes you leave something
on the table off is something on or off
on the table
but these battery parameters capacity
and wrap rate depend on exogenously and
impress take a building ok glutes take a
residential air conditioner let's say
the exogenous temperature is 90 degrees
you really don't have much flex in
operating the duty cycle of the
operation of that thing is gonna hum all
the time okay so when it's very hot
there's hardly any flexibility from your
residential air conditioner what about
when it's very cold well you don't even
that turn the damn thing on so you have
your battery capacity depends on
exogenously
occupancy are you even at home okay on
temperature things like this so what I'm
trying to tell you is that all these
buildings all of which have thermal
inertia and can seed this flexibility
can sell this flexibility as a resource
to director grid and make some modest
amounts of money in exchange you should
view you should look at all of these
buildings as batteries except that these
batteries are random so you have to do
some degree of forecasting of some
exogenous process whether it's occupancy
or weather so you need lead time you
need lead time if you're gonna try and
do this a month in advance it's gonna be
a little hopeless
so maybe add a lead time is not right
either so maybe these intermediate
markets in are in release limiting
dispatch are important to sell demand
response so selling demand response
capability as I said it's different than
generation it's virtual random batteries
there's much greater uncertainty in the
delivery you need a lead time maybe four
hours I don't know I'm guessing it's not
stationary it's not the same battery
every day you have to forecast some
exogenous processes and maybe you sell
demand response capacity in a forward
market that's one one choice maybe you
sell options and this is something that
Sen Lee and dilip are looking at so like
a regular option sold at a certain time
and what you're selling is the
right to use my battery for one hour
starting at some future time and there's
a strike price you pay per unit say
maybe per unit of capacity and there's
an energy use price in case you decide
to exercise the option okay and the
option must be exercised by some
expiration date so I can then maybe if
you don't want to buy it I can sell it
to something else you know what are the
market what is the natural market prices
not just in this context but how much
should we pay for demand response okay
in a market setting or even forget a
market how expensive really if I say
there my responses like generation how
expensive is it is it like ten dollars
in mega whatever five dollars a mega no
two dollars in my gourd are yeah we have
to sort of understand this and this all
this stuff then there's all sorts of
other things one can ask which come from
the theory of mark of market equilibria
so you know how efficient is this how
does this compare with the you know the
gold standard which is the dubrow debreu
arrow sort of market model there okay
keep going
oops that was the beeping dead battery
now it's totally dead
okay so another thought is capacity
markets for balancing this real-time
market it's still a market well why not
just like you have the regulation market
capacity for that why don't we do the
real-time balancing as a capacity so
here's the idea again balancing supply
and demand maybe in a one-hour window
five-minute time slots and inserting a
statistical approach will take us a
deterministic the idea is you have
diverse controllable assets that can
remove uncertainty okay and then there
are like generation like storage like
demand response so the some assets whose
output you can control and you can buy
these assets and they're diverse and you
have other agents that add uncertainty
the system you don't know how much
energy they're going to use like loads
like renewables two sets of agents
agents say adding certainty agents that
remove uncertainty okay and by
uncertainty I'm talking about in the
balancing market so the bulk power you
know the you know if I'm going to if
you're gonna consume five plus minus one
kilowatt hour that side has been taken
care of in the day ahead market now
we're just talking about the plus minus
one okay here's a set up I've divided
this one-hour block into T five minutes
so five one six twelve twelve time slots
reso uncontrollable resource I injects
an imbalance signal E I I don't know it
I model it deterministically as
belonging to this convex set E I if you
sum all these imbalance signals you get
the signal e that is the total imbalance
signal injected by all the
uncontrollable agents it must be dealt
with
i model it deterministically EG i lives
in this set so e which is the sum of
these signals lies in that set that is a
Minkowski sum or
this convex sense now how do i balance
this unknown signal in this setting I
have to purchase in a forward market the
capacity to do so I can purchase
resource k and if i buy one unit of
resource k imagine a battery if i buy
one battery it gives me the right to use
any to supply any power signal in the
set s if I buy two units of that battery
I get 2 s or 2.3 units
I get 2.3 s each unit of this resource
controllable resource K costs pi k qk is
a purchase decision of how much of this
resource
i buy then here's the problem
e is the imbalance signal set i have to
cover it i have to balance the
uncertainty qk is the amount of resource
ki by resource k unit amount of resource
k provides that much of this of my
signal so that's the total thing I've
purchased ok the controllable assets
that I purchase can generate any signal
in this convex set it must contain the
imbalance set and I'm buying QK
resources at price PI K so that's my
total cost his problem minimize over the
decision variables QK that subject to
this set containment problem so come
back to you kind of grow these convex
sets until they cover the imbalance set
II it is a linear program if you assume
that these are vertex polytopes or
convex hull of okay not not have not
specified by half plane it's not the
intersection if they're vertex polytopes
if they're half planes then it'll really
it's a hairy problem so we can do this
so we can solve this it's a linear
program for crying out loud we can solve
this but there's something funny here
when we solve this problem what we're
doing is
if you are given an imbalance signal in
this set we are guaranteeing that we can
allocate controllable assets say RK so
that I balanced that signal but that
signal is not revealed all at once this
imbalance signal is revealed in runtime
so this J star is the optimal resource
procurement under Oracle information
okay I don't know how much uncertainty
I'm going to get you know a minute to
minute so if you want under causal
allocation of resources you have to add
essentially a causality constraint and
that gives me this say J double star
okay and this is something Jo warrington
so it's related very closely to what Joe
did in his thesis you can compute this
optimal resource procurement cost under
under causal allocation but for a
restricted class of policies may be
proportional may be linear time varying
and so on
it reduces to collections in my
formulation or collections of linear
programs then you can introduce this
thing called the cost of course but I
say you can compute upper bounds of the
cost you can compute that exactly
because you don't know what you know you
don't have an exhaustive
parameterization of cause of policies
that ratio we call it the cost of
causality tells you how important it is
that this imbalance signal be revealed
in runtime or the importance of good
forecasts of that that imbalance and we
can actually compute this exactly in
various cases of practical interest for
the particular problem of balancing in
in real time markets it turns out that
this thing is very very close to one
okay for a particular reason that which
akhil and listen are working
so I'd leave it at that that's problem
number 9 and but this is problem number
10 sorry
so here is where a lot of real-time
decision-making is taking place if there
are commercial products out there that
you know home energy management you have
storage PV you have a smart appliance
you have you have all this stuff and you
have to control it
you have uncertainties and when you need
these appliances uncertainty in prices
you know and this couldn't doesn't have
to be a home can be an industrial thing
but people are trying to commerciai mean
I'm sure Honeywell and whoever does
these things is sort of getting involved
in this and you know my home is not
smart the occupants of my home aren't
that smart either but we'll deal with
that ok so there are many opportunities
in my view for real-time decision making
but where and I've given you all these
sort of balconies a little these
problems you know how do they surf it
what is the larger rubric at least as as
we imagine it ok we being are
substantially being a research group
here so we call a grid 2015 because that
will I will not be here in case it
doesn't work out
forty percent renewables more who knows
another interesting thing that we're
trying to that that Dona either looking
at so all these with portfolio standards
is a calculus so that we want forty
percent renewables and some other place
and they're now starting to specify the
second digit you know thirty thirty two
point six percent of renewables by 2030
where are these numbers coming they're
pulled out of you know that what will
the public accept what looks good in
marketing you know is there some
mathematical you know think even
forecasts of fuel per and we think there
is and we're trying to ask these
questions yeah how do you set when you
will so what we see in the future is
lots of renewables and if you have a lot
more renewables distributed renewables
that delays the need for say investing
more in transmission planning which is
expensive because you have to like this
place people you did write of where
what's called eminent domain is that
what it's called so this is the legacy
grid there's the transmission line drawn
thick transmission line tomorrow drawn
thin you don't need it as much and
instead you have generation assets more
power is generated and consumed locally
and the whole sort of distribution side
is grouped into what might be called
clusters or micro grids that are managed
okay and so that's what may be that they
provide local power balance maybe they
exchange energy between each other
through a market how does a market for
interconnected micro grids look like who
assures reliability who is to blame are
we paying too much for reliability
anyway you know it's a lots of
interesting questions of that nature so
you know I guess we need a grid
operating system that's really you know
what what I'm suggesting because there's
so many different kinds of resources we
need some standardization like open ADR
for demand response and we need you know
software tools
- you know - we need to work with those
guys and the other ones anything more
how big should these clusters be surely
a home is not big enough we need some
sort of aggregation I can't be
responsible for power balance or firming
you know how big must they be how what
do I need diversity statistical
diversity don't know what are
performance metrics for this
architecture so some of the things we
might need as I said power quality
reliability is very important you can
imagine within the cluster if it's
eighty-five thousand homes millions of
microtransactions I might sell my
rooftop solar energy in one two minute
chunks to somebody else you know small
transactions you know subset okay how do
you manage that what is a market look
what is the hardware looked like so
there are these companies that are doing
really extraordinary things like virtual
power systems I hope to get them to our
seminar series here some of the
industrial people so you need a
radically new market structure to
support millions of small and diverse
transactions the key word is diverse
because if I'm selling say excess solar
in two three minute blocks I have some
constraints they all have some
uncertainty if I'm selling and I want to
include say conventional generator
selling that maybe have a minimum run
time if I'm selling dr i have a lead
time you have these diverse diverse
constraints and can we manage them in
some clearing place and so we're
thinking about this we call it Apex
automated power exchange and gingi Quinn
who is also going to do this Rama Raju
copilot Stanford and the key idea is to
maybe come up with an atomic set of
commodities that one transaction
smallest five six things and your
particular constraints can be translated
into combinations of these atomic sets
of assets so I might buy I might be
willing to sell two of these and three
of the
for these because of the constraints I
have in producing my my asset okay and
then these are not bilateral
transactions but multilateral
transactions they're not spot market but
a couple of spot markets so you have an
order book where you know their prices
and quantities for these composed
commodities and with these coupled in
this order book how do you clear these
you know first-come first-serve you know
what do you how do you clear these
multilateral transactions so this is you
know something to worry about you know
what are metrics for this marketplace
you know is it like bid-ask spread
transaction Irish daily volume you know
things like this we're trying to
simulate this Jonathan Mathur
gingy Ron rajagopal is fantastic at
Stanford and this is sort of really what
be an another calls transactional energy
that's where we're going so this
collections of micro grids a distributed
leaderless market to clear it
you know that's blotchy you know so you
know but then is blockchain isn't going
to support the the through path least
not now the kind of throughput that we
might need for this but then we don't
need the same security that blockchain
assures because it's micro sense so what
do we need there are many other problems
and there are many fantastic creative
researchers working on many of these
problems you know Shmuel org is right
here is a resource you know there's so
much about market power about
competition models he does is mixed
cournot and Bertrand cournot Bertrand
thank you very much
everything I know is a strict subset of
everything okay okay then
Abhishek has worked on virtual bridge
with Rahul Jane they're both here you
know so it's almost unclear to me why we
needed a boot camp fund on on
electricity sharing the leap is here
Josh Taylor isn't here at Leanne Betar
we'll be here in March hopefully
he's worked on very interesting things
on financial trends storage right Lachey
I think we'd love to hear on his coupon
Lycia it's not here it's right there the
coupon experiment that would be really
nice to hear yeah
data analytics again Lachey's done a
fair bit of work on that and and he's
really organizing at NSF something on
big data in energy you know which you
can tell us more about gaming so dr is
very susceptible to gaming because
there's no natural baseline
it's a counterfactual so there's work on
that with again with delete with iran
and and prepuce lot of you know great
stuff out there though there's a chill
political win let me not like make
things rosier than play sound let you
know what i mean
electricity market innovation is largely
driven by renewables which in turn are
inspired by making by the desire to make
our air breathable for generations or
planet habitable for generations
I've also driven by innovations in
electronics and sensing and storage but
it's really climate change minerals
okay because if you just had coal-fired
plants you know the market structure now
is fine yeah so recent news PV panel
tariffs 30% yeah that's been added or is
it 45 I don't know what it is to Chinese
imports of they're really good at making
it they make it cheap and then by the
way when you do that you lose what
fifteen thousand solar installation jobs
are much higher ping so there's that
FERC is being pushed to subsidize to
bailout coal because because they offer
a resilience subsidy it's what it's
being called they initially opposed the
thing January 8th but now they have been
forced to reopen it and they're going to
come to some middle ground it might not
be ten billion but something you are
paying for that resilience subsidy of
coal
you know but I serve them in at least a
long-term optimist you know because you
know there are many smart people out
there somewhere there are really course
opportunities called elections and so
that's what I wanted to say today at
davos rick perry promotes call us coal
exports us we are exporting freedom so
get this you by call you're free except
you're bound to buy that coal because
you built these coal-fired plants the
only way you're free is if you're buying
renewables because the sun will truly
liberate you or the wind right so I have
a very incomplete list of references
which I'll add to and I'll make
available to the group thank you
[Applause]
I mean so you know the search side it
was perfect 755 people and that's the
one where they recognized this value
services from Batteries service
performance apartment and then they paid
for mileage so basically the distance
the length of the curve and remember
Texas white conference four years ago
the CEO of be name was bragging about
how his auctions for the price per mile
and it was going to zero its we got your
battery and so the thing is that the
batteries won't be fooled twice you know
it's a zero marginal cost product they
spent all this money getting the
batteries and clicking that get dated
mileage and then it went to zero and all
these things are talking a lot of these
things or a zero marginal cost and the
same thing that happened all be excited
things will be happening and then why
won't this disappear and and I I don't
understand the mindset of the power area
so if there was any other field of
engineering it would be a control
question and we talk about contracts for
services I want an aileron company to
supply ailerons and it has to be high
frequency trading no no we're not I mean
you can talk to what it what is the
power purchase agreement I will sell you
but if in real life it's working then
the academic life here isn't working and
that's pretty good
always Boston because he's excited
control
and then and then the control gets mixed
up with the markets it always becomes
five secrets in trade and I know I don't
have any example where it's really been
value anyway that's us too that's and I
have to so much empirical evidence it
cause I think we'd have to have a longer
it's at five o'clock I'm sure all of you
have kids to chill children to pick up
in their wives to feed thank you
[Applause]